my Thanksgiving ended up being pretty
Pleasant most my family members just
avoided talking about politics that's
probably you did to Andy I'm just
curious how was your Thanksgiving my
Thanksgiving it was fine it was fine
you sure Andy no I mean it was fine
Thanksgiving was great it was fine it
was it was fine Andy you're totally
unconvincing answer means it's time for
America's least favorite game show how
was your let's meet our contestants
first up we have Andy Richter Andy I
understand that you work as a talk-show
sidekick that sounds fun Conan you know
that it's no fun okay let's meet our
second contestant he's the Burbank Chief
of Police Glenn hopper Glenn it says
here that you've never been on an
escalator that's not true I've been on
several escalator alright moving on
here's our first question how was your
Thanksgiving Andy you buzzed in first
tell us how was your Thanksgiving well
like I said earlier Conan it was totally
fine oh I'm sorry Andy that is incorrect
chief hopper how was your Thanksgiving
well I was having dinner with the family
when I received a call from dispatch at
5:30 6:00 p.m. to respond to a
disturbance at the Richter residence
next question what was happening at the
Richter residence when chief Hopper
arrived nothing was happening it was a
big misunderstanding chief Hopper
question goes to you what was happening
when you arrived well when I arrived at
the Richter residence the first thing I
noticed was a large refrigerator lying
on the front lawn
I also saw a refrigerator shaped hole in
the side of the house an older man
wearing nothing but boxer shorts was
straddling the refrigerator and mr.
Richter was standing over the old man
screaming not my president those are all
lies mr. Richter was punching the old
man in the face with a raw Turkey that
he was wearing as a boxing glove okay
that last part now tell chief hopper
what he's won
how am I supposed to know it is you've
won a slightly soiled refrigerator when
Andy's uncle's still passed out on it
and a moderately tenderized turkey
that's only been used as a boxing glove
was how was your
[Applause]
great show tonight
star the Great Indoors and author of the
new book
thanks for the money joel mchale is on
the show
from house of cards and the merchants
turf the new movie man down kate mara is
a median alice wetterlund going to
perform levels are going up
[Applause]
you